today I have a very very exciting video
to show you guys and especially you
because I recently came across footage
of Isaac vlogging when he was what like
eight years old from eight to eleven
you've grown a lot so looking back at
this footage he's like so cute and like
I can't wait to see your reaction to the
video and you haven't seen the video we
pulled it out from the vault it straight
from the vault by the way we are
partnering up with DiGiorno for this
video and since we're partnered up why
don't we make a pizza and we'll have a
snack yeah cheese dust crusts one of our
favorites
this is gonna sound the best is you're
on a pizza we've had I don't know I
think I mean stuffed crust was really
really good but pizzeria is still my
number one oh sure that one's pretty
long oh but this is like a twofer this
is like you get the cheese thick there
it is that's the star show
[Music]
turn in delivery is not delivery no all
right goodness so on the road guys is my
first time lot Nelson all right now got
oh yes litter your very first place it's
my first ever vlog it was that I got for
Christmas I'm going to start vlogging in
the cabin and may take over this place
or like take over vlogging maybe sorry
you moving oh yeah awesome I'd wear
cause you're sweet me too it was hard
for me to wake up to all our kids this
camera so wow how cute it is really loud
right here it sounds like an old-school
camera like how are you I know you
didn't think at all I don't want to age
no more I'm done aging if I stay like
this forever what okay you're funny
the cameras taking to the tornado oh if
you dizzy can't zoom in
she is ready and me has been good in the
beginning part it's now going to end
right now
it's just the beginning yeah oh it's my
baby fan phase and we had a concise it's
oh yeah we had a little bit oh yeah it's
nearer what's the place where New
Orleans oh I never knew what Arkansas
was I love that hair
nothing really long you're like just
over your head so cute
let's take a look at the mad [ __ ]
sass yes Louisiana is right below
Arkansas you are geographically correct
I see I looked at the map yesterday you
know iPad he noticed that no those
yesterday hey saucer a saucer shirt oh
you know we get rid of it mmm cutie pie
Maureen carry you how are you good how
smuggling goods you like it oh yes
before you guys thought it was different
noise our side of it quesadilla edit it
okay three years later I did find it is
how are you ready yep barking so you
know where my jack is mother
okay I'm going to do a British shocking
all British very very but yeah where's
my pop back oh thank you very much
mother
mmm Arika pretty I called you mom going
on the car and if you want to know what
how it looks this is a gigantic car
inside I think it's better you know
though it may be a different one but I
really love this van none of it is this
cool comfy
motivation and like hang out and all
right we're I looked a lot like Daddy
and you yeah it meets the others she
Award at the cabin maybe doctor on my
blog a little born
[Music]
[Music]
your baby is all right in Orkut sorry no
and we're outside of the cabin little
bit you don't know the thing though oh
yeah one needs to come before the title
danger stairs may be slippery use handle
Henry oh we're about you
oh yeah ironic hey this is good nice
we're good nice you're like in the woods
would buggy
yeah with a gigantic tripod reason this
is beautiful guys these is very
beautiful so cute
do you feel awkward like a missile yes
really yeah biggest thing I mean really
should we not do this video twice make
sure my younger self the Jean version Oh
baby you're so cute
and look how talkative you were so quiet
room ibadi check out the cabin so
excited be excited too if you wanted all
right let's do this
all right guys oh yeah those are pretty
much got a cabin and as we saw in the
pictures this is my bunk bed where do
they sleep remember yeah you wanna sleep
over
which one you want top or bottom top
riffle address it's right here
oh it's built into it yeah yeah
we also gonna this beam oh dear the
things these are stairs don't cute
little stairs your arm I thought we saw
earlier
all right this is okay I'm little oh no
family who's up here okay
the kitchen there's the door
it's not like you it's all I can tell
you right now there's no anything you
like okay I'm a loner now how do you
feel watching that hilarious that was
just three years ago were you to have
changed so much in that time really I
was like right here yeah like until the
camera can see me I was right here yeah
maybe but now um no it was so cute to
see because I remember you walking
around with the camera you were so happy
to have your camera if I would cuz he
had been asking us for a camera and I
was like oh perfect
christmas is coming up is when we're
going to get you the camera and it's a
waterproof camera which he's been using
in recent vlogs where we went swimming
yeah that's a historical camera is gonna
be years of history it's gonna be an
artifact I'm so cute oh man I love
seeing that like your boy son is so
different
thank you little baby Mexican racer you
still do it ideally of every Chicano
accent yeah we're very heavy to kind of
like that really yeah really
are you really gonna fight it now I have
it - it's our lazy tongue like that's
what I call it it's like our tongue is
like flatter but that was like wow but
that was like instead of like yeah like
but dazzling like was like just to have
a cheek
Chicano accent afternoon
anyways thanks for watching guys make
sure to LIKE and subscribe if you
haven't already and we will see you in
the next vlog hopefully it will be
another bult video actually comment down
below if you want Isaac's vlog to be
uploaded on its own without us talking
over it because I want to rewatch this
without us talking over it again mm-hmm
you guys want us to buy
[Music]
[Music]